Margeaux reveals more than just her
summer bod in the latest sanity fair
issue inside
she talks love scenes revealing her
first ever was in wolf of wallstreet and
even Leo DiCaprio couldn't keep it from
being awkward why actually fire someone
and I'll be right out
the Australian stunner told the magazine
her strategy saying quote the sooner you
do it the sooner you can stop doing it
Margot has become unstoppable her latest
The Legend of Tarzan is out now and be
highly anticipated Suicide Squad hit
theaters next month what was that I
should kill everyone and escape sorry
the voices Margot nails that American
accent so well it's easy to forget this
26 year old beauty is from Down Under
she took a break from her sexy
photoshoot in st. Barths to teach us
some Aussie lingo okay a Blood jaw is
like someone who's lazy hey dink I'm
kind of like far out there's a ripper of
a party but he's a ripper of a bloke
hogs your bathing suit tugs on frothing
for it you're excited for are you froth
those you really like those is there
anything she can't do I've never used
the word Deauville a key in my life I
have no idea what it means